dr thomas wollersheim er betreut bei der
aok rheinland/hamburg die coronel corona
virus hotline und beantwortet die fragen
der versicherten und auch der nicht
versicherten und schönen guten tag und
auch wir haben ganz ganz viele fragen
von zuschauern bekommen und die möchten
wir einmal an sie weitergeben
hier ist die erste ich wollte fragen was
ich dagegen tun kann weil ich arbeite im
hotel in ausbildung bin ich habe ja da
sehr viele gäste kommt hat wie ich da
jetzt aufpassen kann man sich dagegen
tun kann
ich weiß ja nicht ich kann nicht einfach
das team aus dem weg gehen gehen an die
frage geben wir direkt ansehen weiter
aus dem weg gehen ist natürlich nicht
möglich es gibt eine reihe von allgemein
maßen haben wir uns in der situation
helfen dazu gehört zum einen die ganz
banale regelmäßige händedesinfektion dh
das müsst ihr handy regelmäßig besch
wenn das nicht möglich ist kann man auch
ein spezielles gel verwendet das aus dem
weg gehen lässt sich vielleicht je nach
job ein bisschen anpassen indem man
jetzt ein offensichtlich wirklich
eindeutig niesen und husten den menschen
einfach ein wenig abstand zu hält nur
ein zwei meter machen das einen großen
unterschied aus das sind maßnahmen mit
dem man da tut man es gibt weiter kommt
und wir haben eine weitere
zuschauerfrage bekommen schauen wir auch
uns dieses mal an ich wollte mal wissen
wie man sich denn da anstecken kann
was ist die häufigste infektionsquelle
also wie wird das virus am häufigsten
übertragen also nach allem was wir
wissen ist dass eine erkrankung die von
mensch zu mensch übertragen wird und
zwar zunächst mal ganz genau wie
erkältungen und die gruppe an sich
genauso also über eine
tröpfcheninfektion das heißt also durch
niesen durch husten werden die viren
weitergegeben wir können eine ganze zeit
auch auf objekten bleiben also auf die
türklinke oder auf einer tastatur oder
so etwas
und daraus ergibt sich halt auch schon
wieder die sinnhaftigkeit ich regelmäßig
die hände zu waschen und was ganz nicht
ganz einfach ist also auch für uns
profis nicht ganz einfach ist
ich nicht immer ins gesicht so dass man
mit der hand nicht am schleimhäute geht
nicht an den mund nicht an die nase das
bedarf tatsächlich so ein bisschen
konzentration weil das sachen sind die
man jetzt ganz unwillkürlich sonst macht
und dann haben wir noch eine frage von
einem zuschauer bekommen
der eher in die richtung geht was
passiert denn wenn ich mit dem virus
kontakt hatte das müssen wir machen
schützenvereinen zuerst woran merke ich
dass und wie geht es dann weiter wenn
man tatsächlich positiv auf das virus
getestet wurde
also zunächst mal muss man ja sagen ist
es gar nicht so furchtbar einfach zu
merken dass man jetzt spezifischer virus
erkrankt ist das hat damit zu tun dass
die erkrankungssymptome ja ganz ähnlich
sind wie beim banalen erkältungen und
erst bei einem sehr schweren verlauf in
richtung lungenentzündung wirklich
dramatisch man muss aber umgekehrt auch
sagen dass die gefahr für das indy
individuum an sich also für den
betroffenen menschen bei diesen leichten
fällen ja auch gar nicht so groß ist
dass krieg der organismus in 80 prozent
der fälle ganz locker hin und in den
schweren fällen merken dass sozusagen
von selbst
im moment ist die vorgabe die dass die
diagnostik dann erfolgt wenn neben
solchen symptomen gehen sehr viele leute
haben
erkältungen oder eben auch globale
symptome bis die diagnostik dann
einsetzt wenn es zusätzlich einen
definierten kontakt gibt also
beispielsweise zu einem einen direkten
kontakt mit einem betroffenen
nachgewiesenen patienten
das heißt es macht keinen sinn jetzt bei
jedem menschen der husten schnupfen
heiserkeit hat jetzt ein chronist
gemacht hätte auch eingrenzen an der
stelle
und jetzt haben wir noch eine frage die
das alter der menschen betrifft
schauen wir uns auch die einmal ein
bisschen mein name ist gab es wird ja
unheimlich viel gesagt von dem corona
virus man sagt ja immer nur alte leute
wie sieht es aus mit dem mittleren alter
oder mit den jüngeren
also da ist für mich noch nicht genau
definition da ja also meine stars sehr
verunsichert also in dem fall ist es so
dass wir die informationen zu der art
des verlaufes im moment immer noch
sammeln
das heißt es gibt anzeichen aus vor
allem anderen ländern wo wir die
schwerer verlaufende infektionen
wesentlichen erkennen in bayern
beispielsweise sind die infektion die
ganz gut über die bühne gegangen in
deutschland bisher das einen fokus auf
älteren und schwerkranken menschen liegt
das kann man jetzt natürlich nicht an
der jahreszahl festmachen
man kann nicht sagen ab 50 wird es ernst
man weiß es sind mehr männer betroffen
man weiß es sind das höhere lebensalter
spielt ein rolle ist eine analyse wo man
tatsächlich einen zunehmendes risiko in
den 50er jahren hat und richtig riskant
wird eine kombination von om lebensalter
mit schweren chronischen vorerkrankungen
aber selbst das heißt selbstverständlich
nicht dass jeder mensch der in so einem
alter jetzt einen solchen automatik hat
erstens automatisches koma virus hat und
zweitens einen schweren verlauf haben
muss das sind ja ausschließlich
statistische hinweise
wahrscheinlichkeiten über die meere und
jetzt wollen wir einmal in die letzte
zuschauerfrage für heute für den moment
reinschauen
da geht es vor allem um die verbreitung
der krankheit
mein name ist bastuck ich frage mich
warum das corona virus sich in so kurzer
zeit so weit ausbreiten konnte trotz
sicherheits dämmung sehr gute frage
gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten das
hat natürlich mit ganz vielen
verschiedenen sachen sollten zum
beispiel ist das kona virus also auf der
einen seite etwas anstrengender als das
grippevirus gruppe ist ja etwas das wird
ja sehr oft verglichen was in
deutschland gang und gäbe ist im prinzip
sich auf lange nicht so viele leute für
interessiert haben bevor jetzt einer
infektion kam
dazu kommt dass die welt natürlich so
dermaßen gut vernetzt ist dass man ja
alle nase lang liest dass leute die von
irgendwo zurückgekommen sind
die infektion mit gebracht haben dass
natürlich auch zur verbreitung bei und
schließlich und endlich sind die da noch
mal sehr professionellen umgangs
möglichkeiten die wir in dem land für
deutschland haben in anderen ländern
natürlich lang nicht so verbreitet
gewesen das heißt also auch da kann man
durchaus sagen in einer situation in der
man von anfang an dass der konsequenz
hätte umsetzen können wäre vielleicht
alles nicht so schnell gegangen aber das
ist natürlich im nachhinein jetzt auch
so ein bisschen voraus nämlich kann man
es nur in deutschland besser machen
jetzt und da ist der ansatz das ganze
möglichst so weit ein zu denken das ist
eben sich mit einem tempo ausbreitet das
es uns erlaubt mehr aber das virus zu
erfahren eine impfung zu entwickeln ist
bzw
lösungsmöglichkeiten kann diese
krankheit zu entwickeln sich sehr von
uns gewissheit